ce sont des jeunes élèves du cs de la
rue edouard pailleron qui ont allumé un
incendie dans lequel sont mortes
vingt-et-une personnes dont 17 de leurs
camarades ils ont tout avoué aux
policiers la nuit dernière le principal
responsable est un garçon de 15 ans qui
aurait agi par vengeance à la suite de
sanctions et six de ses camarades
étaient au courant de son projet d'avis
et us marquette précisément vous devez
refaire une fois le soir du 6 février
quand la leyre tôt que fut donné rue de
voir pailleron quelques minutes plus tôt
un jeune garçon avait répondu de litres
d'essence sur les corbeilles à papier
l'armoire et les chefs d'une salle
d'étude du rez-de-chaussée
l' incendie devait dire les témoins
s'est propagé à une vitesse foudroyante
à 20h40 ou le bâtiment en flammes s'est
effondré toutefois les sauveteurs
pensaient encore qu'il n'y avait aucune
victime
malgré la présence dans l'établissement
au moment de l' alerte d'une
cinquantaine de personnes
il s'agissait de jeunes enfants âgés de
8 à 13 ans élève du conservatoire
municipal de musique venus un cours de
solfège accompagnés de leurs professeurs
entre 18 heures et 19 heures 30 au ciné
club de l'école on projetait le film
alexandre le bienheureux
après la séance le jeune pyromane
pénétra dans la salle d'étude du
rez-de-chaussée quelques heures
auparavant
anne ses camarades avaient acheté 2
litres d'essence dans une droguerie du
quartier j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
enflammé naissance que j'ai répondu
déclara le jeune incendiaire à ses
camarades et complices ils l'attendaient
à l'extérieur
à ce moment là le groupe ignorait qu'une
soixantaine d'enfants de l'orage se
trouvaient à l'intérieur et vers 22
heures ce qui n'était jusque alors qu'un
violent incendie devint brusquement une
tragédie plus de deux heures après le
début du sinistre les sapeurs pompiers
en pillant les décombres du cs
découvrait les corps des victimes
désaveu terrible la nuit dernière ce de
cette jeune garçon le plus âgé à 15 ans
le plus jeune à peine 14
les enquêteurs qui avaient dès le début
retenu l'hypothèse de l' incendie
criminel au même titre que les autres
hypothèses avaient commencé dès le
lendemain de la catastrophe par
interroger tous les élèves
qui avait fait l'objet de sanctions
durant ces derniers jours et qui aurait
été susceptible par conséquent de mettre
le feu aux us pour se venger